if you do decide to run in the next few
months obviously it will then be UV
Donald Trump for the Republican
nomination people have been quite kind
of scathing they've said you're house
trained Donald your diet coke to his
full Coke right you've heard all this
stuff what are the differences between
you well I mean I think there's a few
things I mean obviously you know the
approach to covid was different I mean
you know I would have fired somebody
like fauci uh I think that he got way
too big for his britches and I think he
did a lot of damage I also think just in
terms of my approach to leadership you
know I get Personnel in the government
who have the agenda of the people and
share our agenda if you bring your own
agenda in you're gone we're just not
going to have that so the way we run the
government I think is no daily drama
focus on the big picture and put points
on the board and I think that that's
something that's very important